under no circumstances should anything
from our ancient past be kept hidden
from the public however the
never-before-seen photos and video that
i'm going to share with you will prove
that we the general public have not been
shown everything that there is to know
you see the great sphinx of giza egypt
has long been subject of debate with
many theories suggesting that there are
perhaps secret tunnels and chambers
located within and under this mysterious
ancient archaeological site
between legends of a so-called hall of
records or the modern scientific data
which has identified possible chambers
that are under and within the sphinx
and even this notable off-limits passage
located at the back end of the monument
which has long generated intense desire
by many to know what's down there you
see this was discovered and excavated in
the 1970s by world-renowned
egyptologists zahi hawas and mark laner
in fact real quick you have to see this
short clip about it
it began with an old worker who
remembered a secret tunnel in the
sphinx's rump
[Music]
they removed a single stone from just to
the left of the sphinx's tail
and sure enough
we saw this passage
going down in and under the sphinx
they descended into the shaft
of course we didn't know where it was
gonna go
and so three weeks i spent
down in the darkness
underneath the great sphinx
we search it everywhere
but there is nothing hidden underneath
so just to clarify they spent an entire
three weeks excavating an empty tunnel
so this is the part where things get
weird because you should know that these
still images from the clip you just saw
are quite literally the only examples of
this tunnel that have been ever made
available to the public and notice that
they do not show where that tunnel goes
and in fact we see nothing more than the
entrance of the tunnel itself but not
only that the original 16-page report on
the excavation of this tunnel only
includes these pictures and
illustrations that you're seeing here
this is it and half of them are from
outside of the sphinx
but so what i mean they assured us that
there's nothing down there anyways right
we search it everywhere
but there is nothing hidden underneath
whoa wait a second what was that last
part he said
but there is nothing hidden underneath
nothing hidden underneath underneath
underneath nothing hidden underneath
well those words are about to become
quite interesting especially the
underneath part
now i can neither confirm nor deny where
these photos or videos i'm about to
share with you came from but i can say
with absolute truth that no this is not
me and no i did not take any of the
photos or videos that you're about to
see
nor was i in the country of egypt when
they were taken
however a few brave and cunning men took
great risk to climb down into the back
end of the sphinx at a moment when the
overseeing egyptian authorities were
preoccupied these gentlemen only had a
few seconds before they were ultimately
caught however the photos and short
video clips successfully made it out so
first things first let me play the two
video clips before i show you the photos
as the video clips will set the stage
for what the pictures are going to
reveal to all of us
now real quick i removed just a few
seconds of the clip to conceal this
man's identity but here are the last few
seconds
please
no no
and as you could probably tell that is
when they were caught now here is the
second clip which is of the second
gentleman who was already down in the
second tier at the same time as the
other man was climbing down as you just
saw
okay so that's a good end
here we are under the sphinx
in one of the forbidden holes
now obviously the video was recorded in
great haste and doesn't show us a lot
however there are a few important
details that we just learned but let me
first point out that you cannot see the
entrance of this tunnel when looking
down from the outside of the sphinx as
it's below the first tier and too far to
the left
another thing we observed is that we
never had witnessed where this tunnel
goes or what it even looks like within
it
but it is indeed a dead end so when
zahiawa said there is nothing underneath
he was apparently telling the truth at
least at this particular location
but this is where things get very
interesting because he did not say
anything about there being nothing
inside of the sphinx and the photos
you're going to see next are of a
previously unknown tunnel that proceed
up and inside of the sphinx itself and
these images are the first ever of their
kind to be seen by the public or even
posted to the internet for that matter
in fact i have waited and many others
have waited years to see what these
photos are about to reveal to us first
notice this frame here which is from the
last few moments of the prior clip you
see that this is a second tunnel that
goes up and in and is facing towards the
front of the sphinx or to the east
this is something you cannot see from
the outside of the sphinx either as it
is too high and too far in to be
observed even if you're peaking your
head in from the outside passage
and thankfully this cunning gentleman
captured three photos of this second
tunnel and you can see straight inside
of it which is a passage that proceeds
up and towards the front of the sphinx
and has quite literally been boarded up
and i have to say that the first thing i
thought of when i saw these photos is
the ground radar image here which
identifies two possible cavities within
the sphinx which are in the same
direction that this boarded up tunnel
proceeds
unfortunately we cannot see much that is
beyond the boards and i cannot tell
which direction it goes from there
perhaps it proceeds into a second tier
above or another direction we we just
can't tell
but what i do know is that this
particular tunnel was not shown or
discussed by the world's two most
renowned egyptologists where they
specifically stated that there is quote
nothing underneath yet they mentioned
nothing in reference to tunnels within
the sphinx itself perhaps this would
explain why they spent an entire three
weeks exploring the bowels of the sphinx
which we can now see includes far more
than just an empty dead-end tunnel
and you know all of this becomes even
more interesting when we consider that
there is another vertical shaft at the
top of the sphinx
this is something that i discussed in a
video a few years ago but as you can see
here zahi huas himself shows us a trap
door on the sphinx's back which drops
straight down
yet you simply cannot see where it goes
from there but something is now telling
me that is likely connects to the hidden
tunnel which we now know leads in the
same direction and for whatever it's
worth zahi claimed again that there is
nothing down here either just as he
claimed that there is nothing under the
sphinx but i have to say that i am not
at all convinced about that as ground
radar has shown multiple anomalies as
you can see from these examples here
which are located under the sphinx
towards the back end as well as under
the sphinx's left paw or right paw as
you're facing it but
although these photos and videos i
shared with you today leave us with many
unanswered questions i have to say that
i am thrilled to have personally
witnessed and been able to share these
details with you
and if you're wondering why others
haven't successfully snuck down into
this passage and captured pictures or
videos sooner it's related to the fact
that this entire area around the sphinx
is off limits and this you have special
access permission which costs thousands
of dollars and is overseen by tour
guides and armed guards at all times
everyone else is only able to view the
sinks from the top of its enclosure
but make no mistake every one of us has
an inherent right as people to see and
know the details of our lost ancient
past
i don't like secrets and the reality is
that all of us have been kept in the
dark on the prior excavations into the
great sphinx and regardless if you are a
proponent of the academic narrative an
alternative ancient history enthusiast a
history professor an archaeologist or
believer in ancient aliens the one thing
that we all have in common is that we
can now see that all of us have not been
shown everything that there is to see or
be aware of
even if this tunnel goes absolutely
nowhere and nothing was ever found
inside of it we can't necessarily take
that in good faith since we haven't been
included in all the details along the
way because let's not forget
and so three weeks i spent
down in the darkness
underneath the great sphinx
we search it everywhere
but there is nothing hidden underneath
a whole three weeks which was done in
secrecy with a literal shroud concealing
the excavation the entire
time all of us owe a great bit of
gratitude to the brave gentleman that
took the risk to climb down into the
sphinx so we were able to see what we
were today and become aware of the
details that we now know and you know
it's interesting i've been long making
the case that there truly is a mystery
to our lost ancient past something that
many people have adamantly denied but
how can anyone say that any longer when
it's now apparent that there are quite
literally areas they have never knew
existed and of all places at one of the
most famous ancient sites on earth and
you know what else these are not the
only secrets that's been kept from the
public involving ancient egypt i do have
more to share however those are worthy
of videos of themselves
so
stay tuned for that but all of that said
the powers that be within egypt should
release all photos and videos of what's
inside these tunnels because if nothing
else even if there's nothing to see it
will still bring positive light and
and something fun and exciting to look
at to the tourism industry within egypt
itself and to the millions and millions
of people that follow this fun topic
from around the world
that said i'm jimmy my channel is called
bright insight leave a comment and share
what your thoughts are on all of this it
is quite an interesting topic also
follow me on instagram and if you're
interested in supporting me in my
endeavors help support me on patreon as
well i'll leave links to both in the pin
comment down below
but anyways i'll close it up there
thanks for watching take care everyone